I'm Lucas Dul, and I've been repairing
and restoring typewriters
for nearly a decade.
And I'm going to show you how to restore
a 90-year-old Royal typewriter.
This particular machine was purchased new
in India by a family member of my client.
To him, it is a family heirloom.
The serial number places it
in the second half of 1930.
In its current condition,
it is not a functioning machine.
The first pieces to come
off of the typewriter
are the platen knobs
as well as the platen,
which is going to be replaced.
And then I'll remove the body shells.
I'll also remove the paper table,
the bail roller assembly,
the paper tray, and the feed rollers.
Usually, carriage disassembly stops there,
but on cases of really rough machines,
such as this one, the internal type bars
and the actuator rods are all removed
from the machine and set
aside for individual cleaning.
The first step is to pass
with an air compressor
to dislodge large sections
of dirt and debris.
Here, I'm using a wire
brush attachment on a Dremel
to get into hard-to-reach places.
After the bulk of the rust is removed,
everything gets a pass
with mineral spirits
with a soft-bristle brush.
After the cleaning is finished,
all of the bare metal surfaces get wiped
with a rag to remove any residue.
The keyboard on this machine
was also intensely discolored.
Each key ring is carefully
removed from the key top.
I'm using a special key-ring-remover plyer
from the early 1900s.
Anytime that you're working
with a glass keyboard,
you run the risk of breaking keys.
Due to the age of the tool
and the hardened rubber,
about half of these glass circles
in the keyboard ended up shattering.
Once all of the keys are disassembled,
the paper legends are removed.
The individual glass
circles also get cleaned.
Here I'm using a razor blade to scrape off
all of the accumulated corrosion
that is stuck to the surface of the glass.
Then they're each
individually hand-polished
with a fine-grade polishing compound.
If new glass rings need to be fabricated,
they're cut by hand from around
a 16th-inch-thick piece of glass.
This is a common glass standard thickness
for picture frames.
At this point, any
springs that are missing
on the typewriter get replaced.
Over time, they can sometimes stretch
or can become damaged if a machine falls.
Missing or damaged
pieces are also replaced.
I also create new feed rollers
using old rubber hosing
or sometimes layers of heat shrink.
Now I install the paper table.
This is the piece of metal that holds
both the feed rollers in place
and guides the paper around the platen.
The most difficult part about assembling
Royal typewriters are the ball bearings.
Here I'm using a drinking
straw to insert them
into the proper placement
along the carriage rail.
Another tricky part is the ribbon vibrator
or the ribbon lifting fork.
Here you can see me attaching it
with a small cotter pin.
The key legends also need
to be carefully placed
so that they're aligned vertically.
Each key ring needs to be seated properly
with the key-ring-installation tool,
and then once each key top on the machine
is completely set, the bottom plate
of the key-ring-installation
tool gets rotated
to a flat portion of the plate,
which is used to seat down all of the tabs
on the bottom of the key ring
firmly against the bottom of the key cup.
The second-to-last step
is to reassemble everything completely.
All typewriters are individually adjusted
so that the parts work well together.
So when you take certain
parts from one machine
to fill into another machine
that is missing those parts,
you will need to adjust those parts
to work with each other.
Once everything is carefully together,
I install the brand-new rubber
and the feet as well as a new ribbon.
Once the ribbon is in the machine,
the type testing begins.
The primary things that I'm looking for
are evenness of the letters,
alignment between the
capital and lowercase,
margin consistency, and line scale height.
The escapement must also be adjusted
so that it is moving the proper distance
both up and down to prevent
skipping or missed spaces.
Then I move on to adjusting
the height of the ribbon
to ensure that the entire
letter is being printed.
The case is usually a secondary thing
to the typewriter that
I generally don't spend
a lot of time with,
but this particular one
needed a little bit of care.
Unfortunately, the base of the case,
where it mounts to the machine,
had two strips of wood in place
of the four feet that
are supposed to be there
and no way to actually
mount the machine to it.
So here I'm removing these word rails
and then drilling and
counter-sinking holes
for the screws and the feet
that will mount the machine to the base.
The final step is to
cut a strip of leather
and to punch holes to stitch
a new handle onto the case.
This is probably one of the worst Royals
that I have seen, cosmetically.
That being said,
theoretically, there is no
amount of damage that is
physically irreparable.
However, there does come
a point where the cost
of repair far exceeds
the value of the machine,
both monetarily and sentimentally.
And in essence, that is how I
restore antique typewriters.
Any machine from the
mid-1800s to as late as 2020
follows pretty much the
same exact procedures.